ladies and gentlemen with no further Ado
I present to you Bel Air
[Music]
peacock's most streamed original series
Bel Air when I got the script I said oh
this is different
[Music]
let's go
to Bel Air seen one take one marked
you know I think that season one was so
successful because we really tapped into
the authenticity of this story I think
season one was so loved by everybody
because of how relatable it was I think
the fans really responded to season one
because they really felt that it came
from an honest Place one of my best
memories was all the crap people were
talking in the comments and just oh I
can't believe they're about to do this
yeah and then the day that the trailer
came out I I got so many apology texts
because they're like wow this is about
to be dope this is crazy so I think
that's why people loved it because it's
so different it affirmed what we had
done for what five months yeah I think
you can't but not fall in love with the
story of how Bellaire got made it's rare
that you see sort of black male
characters like Uncle Phil Jazzy Jeff
and Jeffrey so the way we talk to each
other leading into vulnerability you
know I think we are definitely not
playing stereotypes come on man we both
know my real job is to protect you and
your family sometimes those two things
don't align the Hiatus for me was
definitely heavily music centered I
dropped AEP
I shot a bunch of music videos I
performed a lot of places I played a lot
of golf and I was working I played
Admiral April on Star Trek strange new
worlds I just had a new baby brother so
I've been spending time with family at
home the minute season one wrapped I
pretty much just retreated back into the
studio I got a studio at the crib and
I've just been writing I've been
producing I've been working on music so
I have a four-year-old it was so great
just to have like focused time to parent
but also shot two films
and she's very successful the way my
life has changed you know from the
beginning when I step out the house I
wear my best things because I don't know
who I'm going to run into I don't want
to look busted and be like oh yeah I saw
a jazz yeah
I was sitting down in New York and I was
eating with my family and this kid walks
up to me and he's like hey I love your
show he's probably like 9 10 years old
he was like can I take a picture with
you and his mom walks up she was like
yeah he just got his haircut like that
because she likes the show and I was
like wow the reach is insane like this
is wild the the love that I get from the
UK in terms of you know how we are and
how I'm portraying Jeffrey that was very
important to me because representation
is is key and important on set my
proudest moment was the last scene of
the season and me and Jabari on that
hill and just how vulnerable I was
episode three would be the Alpha Phi
Alpha the fraternity that was a very
special episode for me because I've
always wanted to be a frat for me it was
that moment at the premiere the whole
cast came together and met will for the
first time that was so magical
premiere for season one was one of the
most magical most special things I've
ever experienced it was during covid so
we couldn't have the premiere inside it
essentially functioned like a drive-in
movie and so you know we're in this
parking lot the episode airs and you
know it's like Bel Air and everyone just
starts honking
it was sort of this realization that we
really have made something special I met
Gabrielle Union and she was
[Music]
she was like oh looking behind me like
what so she's talking about and I was
like oh my God but meeting those people
that you've looked up to your whole
childhood it's a crazy feeling I loved
when I read a tweet uh saying uh this
Jeffrey is not your dad so your parents
Jeffrey you know that made me laugh
you know Jeffrey's a snack I haven't
heard that one before Hey Jeffrey
looking good as ever Joan I'm just
trying to keep up with you
so when we left will at the end of the
end is in one he was walking out of the
banks doors and he was on his own with
jazz but I gotta do this right for me
well well
well it really ended in a broken place
of can I trust them I don't know who to
trust he's seeking outward attention
from the world outside to to find that
camaraderie with somebody else and not
just in his family and so we get to see
him finally fighting for his freedom we
left off on Ashley speaking about her
sexuality and trying to figure out who
she is this new season we tune in to
more of her activism Vivian Banks ends
the season winning that Neiman
fellowship and you see like she finally
gets her art out into the world people
finally get to see it and feel even you
know says it's okay for her to continue
her work and relationship with Reed when
we come back you sort of see the
challenges of working with a person like
Reed where we leave off with Carlton I
think that he's found a bond in a real
kinship with Wilson addition to his life
he's sort of feeling the void of not
having well around all the time he ran
away and
and I don't know if he's going to come
back so you have to help me find him
please in season two I think fans can
expect to to see that relationship
explored more I think fans can be
excited to see where my relationship
with jazz progresses to I know that that
was like a huge comment it's like
everyone's rooting for jazz they want
him to finally you know get with Hillary
because in the OD version she was not
having it we left for a season with with
me dropping out of the race and also
will leaving the house he sees a lot of
himself and will and he didn't he felt
like he he failed will so he really
wants to make that up this season and
find you know his new his career you
know get his career back
yo hey guys it's Jabari Banks here I'm
super super excited to get started back
with Season Two Season Two day one
feeling comfortable and excited
this is my first day it's my first day
sure this is all right this is our day
one first day and shoot it that's so
it's so extra of course thanks we have
to do this on a yeah coming back season
two day one I was like do I remember how
to be for a second they're almost like
do I know how to act still I was like
what's what's going on but but I I
quickly got readjusted the thing about
doing things right is
a senior because everybody knows you it
just felt like we picked up from where
we left off everybody's on Hiatus you
know a lot of the crew were on different
jobs and you know some of the members of
the cast had down time and so for us to
all come back together that first day
and you know everybody's just super
excited and catching up um you know the
the feeling was electrifying just to be
you know back with the Banks family
Adrian I did our first scene as soon as
it was action he started talking and I
started talking I was like so it was
just magical action and we both knew
what that thing was we show we show up
our first thing back was on a yacht and
it was windy as hell I had to change my
hairstyle mid scene because it was
blowing all over the way it's giving
Pocahontas and then sweetie was there
and it was hot it was hot and then it
was cold and then the sun it went away
mad fast
welcome to season two episode 201
written by our very own Carla Banks
waddle we're going to find out some
things that feel surprising to us and
that take us in surprising Direction
so I can't reveal too much but just wait
and see having Carla as the showrunner
for season two has been phenomenal being
able to step into this role is such an
honor and you know I've been doing this
for a long time now I don't want to say
how long but there's been so many times
where we just don't have the space to
tell our stories on television in a full
and authentic way and here we have this
full family and we've got now two
seasons to be able to tell their stories
and delve into them happy to be here
come on now Carla's phenomenal having
her you know take on the mantle
showrunner it's such a you know I know
that that is a a job with with so much
responsibility every time I see Carla
I'm like hey Carla how you doing she's
so calm so before we did this we
actually did a pilot from Malcolm D Lee
that she was the showrunner for you
could say me and Adrian would only have
this job it was because of Carl and
wattles and y'all all when you see
season two I'm telling you Carla did the
damn thing I feel like she hasn't missed
a beat with continuing to keep this show
relevant and modern and pay attention to
detail and and make sure that everyone
feels heard as well
we have some dope cameos and reoccurring
uh stars that that are coming in to fill
these roles and so I'm super excited for
the world to see them as well I
definitely think it's a pleasant
surprise that sweeties in our first
episode honestly the banks they would
know sweetie they would know the top I
mean actresses and artists because
they're an influential family so I just
feel like that's another way of making
the show more modern and cool it's an
honor to be here and shout out to the
cast I really don't know they Vibes and
this is a really cool party scene in the
premiere episode we will meet a
character named doc who will is trying
to desperately meet and try to do
something to transform his basketball
Journey what's up my name is Brooklyn
McLean and my character is the diggy
diggy doc y'all play Doc hightown
basketball coach recruiter Mentor
extraordinaire he feels like home for
will I think that's what happens during
this season in general it's like finding
the Philly and Cali we also meet a young
lady named Jackie who is an homage to
the original series Jackie who comes
from a whole different world that is not
of Bel-Air hi my name is Jocelyn Martin
and I'm playing Jackie on Belair so the
Jackie character was played initially by
Tyra Banks and I feel very honored and a
lot of pressure but it's good pressure
I'm excited to tell this this version of
Jackie and I think in the premiere
episode we also meet the character of
James as we talk a little bit about
Uncle Phil's storyline and meet the
partner that he found at this law firm
with and also let's not forget Yasmin
you know Carlton deserves some love too
we have Tatiana Ali
en
literally when I read that she was going
to play Ashley's teacher that was crazy
never let anyone try to change you you
know I imagine that's almost spiritual
right honestly she was crying because
she saw me portraying her and I just
felt so touched and honored that I am
portraying her right in her eyes I think
that the most interesting part about our
show is finding out more about each
character individually oh my God why is
Jeffrey getting fired is Aunt Viv is she
gonna cheat with Michael Ealy is Hillary
going to succumb to the pressure of
being social media famous like the
audience getting to see more characters
of what they do and where they're from
and why they're doing what they do
really wanting to tell the story of will
this season of how is he going to find
his way back and build trust and is he
going to come back into the bank's
mansion and how can he hold on to parts
of himself that were that way Philly
version of himself while still trying to
become this young man he's still
figuring out in Bel Air what you're
about to see this season there's nothing
like you've ever seen before people
should watch season two of Bel Air for
the same reason that I said they should
watch season one it's good as [__] what
other show can you watch that can make
you have suspense and at the same time
make you feel Nostalgia and like all the
good feelings of love and home I don't
know why it feels like good Chicken Soup
for the Soul of this show like excellent
black excellent
we couldn't be more excited about our
premiere on February 23rd and you know
hope it's a beautiful celebration you
know for the fans for the cast for the
crew you know what there's gonna be more
family more fights more love more
Community more discourse and it's just
gonna be bigger and better I'm super
excited for season two and I'm super
excited for everybody to come back and
see what's going on with the Banks
family it's gonna be crazy period
[Music]
foreign